in the movie interstellar
a landicraft explores a planet near a
black hole that has a mass 100 million
times that of the sun
the crew spent just a few minutes on the
planet but when they return to the main
ship
23 years have elapsed i've waited years
it's 23 years
4 months 8 days the idea of time
dilation by going into deeper
gravitational fields
is actually pretty accurate
first theorized by einstein in his
theory of relativity
it's known as time dilation
the very bizarre thing is that when
you're in a place where gravity is
stronger
time moves more slowly but that's not
all
another way time dilation occurs is
through your relative movement through
space
[Music]
if you have two observers that have
clocks that take at exactly the same
rate
and then one of those observers moves
away at very high speed
the moving observer's clock will tick
more slowly their time
will literally pass slower and a lot of
people are confused by this because i
think it might be a mechanical thing
it's the clock
but no it is in fact literally time it
doesn't matter what the clock is
it can be a clock it could be your
heartbeat it's time
[Music]
this is even true for someone who is
walking compared with someone sitting at
a table
time moves slower for the person who is
walking
similarly for gravitational time
dilation
someone who is at sea level compared
with someone on a mountain
will also experience time at a slower
rate
that's because gravity is stronger when
you're closer to the earth's center of
mass
but in these examples the amount of time
dilation is
so minuscule that it's totally
unnoticeable
apart from a few examples humans don't
deal with fast enough speeds
or enough gravity to experience a
significant amount of time dilation
but that may not matter because atomic
clocks are reaching a sensitivity
that can measure even the tiniest amount
of time dilation
[Music]
i think that's the place where
relativity will start to become far more
important it's because not because we
can go so fast i mean i wish we could go
fast
but i think the real place will be
because we can measure things with
an incredible precision that's amazing
that level of precision will enable us
to use time in ways we
never thought possible like monitoring
tectonic plates
large movements deep below earth's
surface and climate change
atomic clocks could even lead to new
discoveries regarding the nature of time
itself
i think that's one of the really
exciting things about this is that we're
really you know exploring the unknown
we're able to sense effects
that no one has been able to see before
using the precision of the clocks
in 2010 two ultra precise synchronized
atomic clocks were put next to each
other
now these clocks were so precise that
they would lose about one second over
the history of the entire earth then
one of them was raised by just 33
centimeters
the result the clock that was higher up
began to tick faster
but nothing was wrong with the clocks it
was actually
time that sped up for the higher clock
relative to the lower clock
due to the tiniest decrease in gravity
as the clock moved higher up
ultra precise clocks measured the
effects of relativity
side by side being changed by
that much absolutely amazing fantastic
experiment atomic clocks were used in
the 70s for that very purpose
testing relativity and other scientific
experiments
they flew some atomic clocks on
airplanes around the world
compared to the time before and after
doing that what they found confirmed
their predictions
time slowed down for the moving clocks
the technology ended up being integral
to devices that we depend on every day
gps global navigation satellite systems
depend on atomic clocks to help
determine where you are
the time it takes for a signal traveling
at the speed of light to reach your
phone
will give you the distance using four or
more of them
you can triangulate your position you
know i really think of the atomic clocks
as
constantly working in the background you
don't see it
but atomic clocks are really important
for having the whole thing run
the invention of gps meant that time
dilation suddenly went from being a cool
theory
to something that needed to be dealt
with on a daily basis
due to the speed at which the satellites
are orbiting the earth 14
000 kilometers an hour and the lower
gravity in space
they're actually experiencing time
differently relative to us on earth
if you add everything up the clocks
change by about
40 microseconds 40 millionths of a
second of a day which sounds like
nothing
but if you did not take that relativity
into account
every day your position on your receiver
would say that you were six miles off
from where you actually are so
it would very quickly be completely
useless
these dramatic effects of relativity are
central to the work done here at the
national institute of standards and
technology
or nist in boulder colorado
nist is a leader in the development of
optical atomic clocks
these clocks use lasers to control atoms
and measure their oscillations
atomic clocks are currently the most
stable and accurate way of measuring
time intervals and like any other clock
at the heart of an atomic clock is a
very stable
oscillator so you think about a
grandfather clock
it has a pendulum that serves as the
reference oscillator it oscillates at
one cycle per second
an atomic clock is very similar so at
the heart of an atomic clock
is an oscillator which is the atom
itself
instead of having a bunch of gears and
levers and springs and things
it's a series of lasers
atoms trapped in an electric field
receive a series of pulses
which aid in controlling and measuring
their oscillations
instead of one tick per second these
clocks oscillate or tick
a million billion times per second
allowing for
much more precision so it's a really
small inaccuracy it's hard for anyone to
conceptualize
that level of performance these clocks
are
so reliable that it would take more than
double the age of the universe
so around 30 billion years to drift by
even a second
that precision means relativity can also
be measured with
incredible accuracy
so if you move a clock up by one
centimeter of height
it will tick faster by this
one part in 10 to the 18 and now we can
detect that kind of change
although this kind of precision could be
problematic since atomic clocks keep the
official time
that synchronized devices all over the
globe
that seems like a huge problem i mean
how do you decide where to place the
clocks if just
the tiniest change in gravity causes
time to slow down or speed up
that is a good point and it's a problem
that we're sort of
anticipating now the
clocks are getting so good that we don't
know their gravitational
potential well enough to define
time globally at that same level it does
seem like a simpler environment
somewhere out in space farther away from
these local
gravitational variations
the problem of determining standard time
aside this
one centimeter level precision has the
potential to revolutionize the way
things are measured
using clocks to calculate height and
gravity
based on the amount of time dilation
this is particularly useful in geodesy
the study of the earth's shape
orientation in space
and its gravity field
we're studying the the motion of the
crust of the earth
plate tectonics the tides
the polar motion of earth there are many
many effects that are observed and that
can be explained
for instance in sweden and canada it's
rising on the order of one to two
centimeters per year that's quite a lot
and on another part of our planet
there's actually a downward land
movement so somewhere it's going up and
somewhere it's going down
and such effects of course change
everything like the global sea level
earthquakes they change even the
rotation of the earth
and much more
understanding these movements can help
aid in understanding climate change
natural hazards and construction of
major structures like bridges and roads
atomic clocks were used in this field
they could in theory
give you height measurements that are
sensitive to just one centimeter
a level of accuracy gps is not capable
of
and because current methods utilize gps
and a gravimeter for determining gravity
at a single point
it doesn't always give you a clear
picture of what's going on
well i'm from germany so let's give you
an example
in germany we're proud to have our
highest mountain it's called
such pizza it's almost 3000 meter high
but also this mountain has permafrost
underneath
which is now melting and that actually
gives rise
to a shrinking of the mountain so the
top of the mountain is
probably decreasing but also one or two
centimeters per year
but we have not observed and measured it
yet
because at that place if you would put a
gravimeter
you would not see this signal because on
the mountain you have a varying snow
cover
from summer and winter the snow is
changing the groundwater level is
changing and all these
local changes in mass are disguising the
actual effect
so if you would combine now your
gravimeter with a clock on top of such a
mountain
then you really could resolve what the
melting of the permafrost is doing to
the to the alps
because the clock would not be sensitive
to a very local mass change like
a snow cover but it will really uh
measure an average mass and then
gravitational potential and really show
you the physical height of the mountain
[Music]
that's why geodesy missions using atomic
clocks are expected to take place in the
next few years
so there's actually a mission in germany
where geodesists
want to make for the first time a clock
measurement they want to blink bring a
clock to helgoland this is
the offshore island in the northern sea
um to compare and get the data because
at the moment this island could
not be leveled it's too far out in the
ocean and satellites
would not resolve it it's too small and
that's why there's right now geodetic
mission
to bring a portable atomic clock to this
island
and compared to a continental clock
helgeland's location and size make
getting precise height readouts
difficult
using gps with gravimeter data requires
multiple readouts
every two kilometers so offshore areas
or areas near ashore
technically require you to place a
gravimeter in the ocean which isn't
possible
that's why the island's elevation hasn't
been accurately measured to this day
clocks can bridge the gaps to islands
deserts or mountainous areas
which are hard to access with classical
leveling methods
in turn they can also act as height
reference points for understanding ocean
dynamics and global sea levels
but it's not all about geodesy we may
even learn things about gravitational
effects that we don't entirely
understand
it's hard to predict what the
measurement will tell you
but certainly we're up to many surprises
and this is actually the boundary that
we physicists are trying to push
now to measure more and more precise
time frequency space time
as we know it's connected in general
relativity atomic clocks
could be the key to answering some of
the biggest mysteries in physics today
that shape the universe as we know it
dark matter
we know that there's dark matter that's
making up most of the matter
in the universe and there are also
you know models of dark matter that can
be
searched for and constrained using
atomic clocks so
there are a lot of scientific
applications
clocks get more precise we could find
that constants used in everyday physics
equations are wrong
and that could completely change how we
understand the universe
atomic clocks that we're building are
the most sensitive way
to look for this present day variation
in the
fundamental constants it really has the
potential
to revolutionize physics
so do you think atomic clocks could lead
to an einstein-esque discovery about
time
i think it's certainly possible if
we did detect that there was a
drift in the fundamental constants over
time
that would be a revolution similar to
you know the discovery of relativity or
the discovery of quantum mechanics
basically we're doing a lot of tests on
the predictions
of albert einstein because can we really
assume that general relativity is
the sole theory explaining everything
or is there maybe a deviation from the
predictions that general relativity
makes
the fact is i don't think we do
understand time very well
it's always possible that there is going
to be some
bright young person out there who's
really
terribly disturbed by the the conundrum
of time
and thinking it over and might come up
with something brilliant but
it's going to require a different way of
thinking it's going to require
that flash aha moment that happens once
per century or even
once per millennia
you